yara and jovi this is your first
90 day run so i have to ask you are you
watching the season back so far
yeah i've been watching and it's been
interesting you know not what i expected
and you know seeing myself on tv first
of all it's like the most shocking thing
and like hearing my voice is weird so
i'm watching but i am so sad to say i
skipped the other proper what is what
you want to watch ourselves
yeah hey what's going on
i don't know well what other couple are
you feeling right now who who else are
you into
i like uh julian brendan i like
uh uh stephanie she looks so good i like
how she looks she'll separate
i look i wish i will look at like she
look at her age well jovi
you're getting a lot of attention online
a lot of attention from women
who want you to leave yara and get with
them
right so yeah
how do you feel about that did you
expect your man to become like a 90-day
heart rob
what can i do i'm sure no
i can say what can i do like he's a
handsome man let's be honest and uh
of course he will get attention that was
new right so i want to kick somebody's
ass sometimes but no i can't do that
and a lot of fans just want to know what
is it that makes you two compatible
because sometimes it doesn't even seem
like you like each other to be honest
you know sometimes for us it seems like
it doesn't even make sense sometimes too
but it does you know um we have we have
a lot in common and most people don't
see you know we're both very family
oriented we both
uh have a lot of the same likes but oh
you cut
there is something which people can't
see you can't see when you just see us
we have so much the same thing inside
yes we outside look different maybe i
talk different maybe i like
more classy stuff enjoy don but there's
something inside in our character which
we have character which we have the same
um even if it does not look like that
the second thing we need to always
remember that
it's when we was for example doing that
we was not alone never in the room and
you always
are different than when you're just
listening without cameras and all that
stuff
it's just a little bit for example for
me i feel more shy
and maybe i was when i was more cool
sometimes or something
yeah i just noticed a clip the other day
i was like oh i love you and then she's
just like silent
yeah that does make a lot of sense and i
think that's something for fans to think
about
watching it i don't you know think about
the pressure you're also feeling because
cameras are all around
you know we're so used to you just
following your everyday moves but it is
a lot of pressure having those cameras
up 24 7.
yeah and when you kiss him for example
and somebody looked to your mouth
it's just like oh you know you just kind
of can do that at the same time you
always want to look good and you want to
look like i am cool here you know
yeah we're having like a fight who could
be the cooler one on camera
i think yara has you beat there jovi
sorry about that i have to ask you yara
do you still think
jovi dresses disgusting have you stepped
his fashion game up
i dressed joey she just told me what
shirt to put on for my interview
come on it works and for joby things
because i buy for him clothes and now he
addressing perfect
and he has a nice haircut now and
everything does help me
look you taught a lot of women you know
that you don't always have to have the
full package you can tweak and fix some
things you know
as long as you have the character as you
said that's what matters
and the good looks all right well yara
in sunday's episode
we see that you have a pregnancy scare
at least you
think that you are pregnant and you
admit that you're not ready for kids
so my question for you is do you still
feel that way do you still feel like
you're not ready for kids
not that i am not ready for kids the
fact that i am not
ready to have a kids uh on the other
country where they don't have my friends
and family
when i don't know what's can going on i
want to have a kid so much how everybody
knows no i was pregnant before and i
have missed edge it was so much hard for
me because i was really on that baby so
much
they found that i don't know how i can
do that by myself and all of these
things
and i don't know which i will do if
something happens to joey this is what's
more scared me than have a kiss the
[ __ ] to have a kids
yeah yeah well i'm not sure if you all
have seen the rumors i'm sure you have
that you two are married and that you
have a baby girl
i have to ask you i know you probably
can't tell us much
if it's true or not but how do you feel
about those rumors circulating
oh we see a lot of rumors from us being
married i was having a baby from
uh i mean your yard is deported like i
mean you name it has happened so
i mean everybody's gonna have to watch
the show to find out but
it's gonna be interesting i mean we have
a good story to tell i
promise you that yeah well y'all you
brought up your miscarriage
and i commend you you did a very brave
thing
as we talked about the cameras to be
that vulnerable in front of cameras and
to be that emotional
that's pretty brave i just want to know
how you felt
after dinner with jovi at your apartment
what were the thoughts going through
your head
you know um like that situation is just
so much sensitive for me and always when
i remember you just
it was just giving me a coffee honestly
i'm not really like someone said with
joey i really understand that humans
need to go to work and next time
it just was the fact that i was staying
alone you know i country and i was just
so much sad and of course
because i was in that time in julia
forgive him that i
i was i'm not mad just because when
somebody started to talk to me about
that it just
again make me maybe mad or sad i don't
know and i again start to feeling like
that
yeah i feel like i got a bad rap for
that you know i left her to go to work
and we didn't know she was gonna have to
go to a doctor and had this operation
and everything in albania
so i left thinking like she's gonna go
back to ukraine in a few days she'll get
her passport back and go back
and then she'll see a doctor in ukraine
and figure out what'll happen next
well she started having stomach pain and
had to get rushed to the emergency room
and
things happened a lot faster than either
one of us really expected
yeah so are you two on the same page
when it comes to that because on the
show you had
different stories different you know
recounts of what happened
are you on the same page with that or is
there still some resentment there
yara till today day i think that julio
was can
ask uh asking the boss to give him two
days off and just go with me to the
operation
that's it but i am like it's already
happened yeah and
i need to forgive that i was staying
with this person because i love him and
uh because i would want to spend time
with him like um
but at the end of the day yeah she's
still mad at me for that
yeah and i mean that's it's
understandable
i get it too honestly well i'm glad to
see you know you two are
moving forward when it comes to that i
want to talk to you jovi about sarah
your friend oh man let's hear it your
friend
ladies let's talk about that
were you shocked when when you saw that
she told yara your history
with strippers how did you feel about
that i was shocked two days ago because
i didn't know anything about it until
then
what yeah y'all didn't tell me anything
sarah didn't tell me anything
production didn't tell me anything i was
like left in the dark i watched the
episode i was just like
so how did you feel i mean i felt like i
got thrown under a bus
a big one was she telling the truth
i mean yeah i hung out the strip club a
lot but i mean she made it sound a lot
worse than what it really was
yeah have you spoken to her about it
because i mean the first thing i thought
was
it seems like you two may have like a
big sister little brother relationship
or some you know
maybe there's some understanding there
but it seemed as if she didn't even want
your relationship with yara to work
not that much understanding i mean that
was that was brutal
oh okay so you have some feelings about
it yeah of course i mean who wants to
get thrown under the bus like that
i don't think anybody yeah especially
you know i'm trying to marry this woman
and here she just goes
goes to town on me yeah and what did you
how do you feel now about what sarah
said y'all i know on the show you said
that you just didn't understand
she probably thought it was funny or
whatever else but how do you feel about
it now
honestly if i would listen to everybody
who tell me some stupid stuff and listen
to life i will be
i don't know which i will do i will
never be with you and i will be with no
one but because i don't listen nobody i
read my own mind why would you
listen to sarah tell me she is not
joey's sister she's not jeremy's family
and
how why would you care which was in the
past individuals xp hundred million time
on the bed i don't care that was joey's
past
yeah i was before well it seems like you
don't really have an interest as as far
as right now
in the series or season it doesn't seem
like you have an interest in getting to
know jovi's mom that much
or you know allowing her to get to know
you are we gonna see your relationship
get better
you see probably because i'm a different
mentality person and now maybe different
express my feeling and everything but
for me
uh before i arrived to america i was
already
sure and knowing that joey's mom is so
cool because one time i have a talk by
skype and she's a school person so when
i saw her first time i feel i'm like
she's really cool but probably the way
i'm expressing myself
everybody can understand different
things but no i like her she's nervous
okay well let's talk about that what do
you think the biggest misconception
is that fans have about you what do you
think that they just
don't get or don't understand like faint
thinking i guess that i'm
so much rude and mean and all of it and
like how they did
all the backwards whatever they call me
no the fact is that
i am uh open and no lying right if i
don't like person i say i don't like you
don't be my friends
i will know love to your face and after
talk [ __ ] about you and your back
i'm telling everything the truth people
from i guess different mentality cannot
really got that they think that i'm just
too much rude but no i'm just trying to
be open and if i don't like someone i
say yes guys
i don't like this i will not laugh and
smile it's so much cool
and after i'll go on the street and you
see you know what
you're a piece of he she's a piece of
[ __ ] i really hate her but i was still
going smiles on her face i'm not doing
that and i guess ben doesn't understand
it really
yeah a lot of people think too you're
always worried about money
or like they may call you a gold digger
there are other things too
like some like not if people tell me
like i am
beach i'm like okay it's true i'm on the
beach
or i don't know whatever they call me
but when they call me goldie it just
like pissed me off i'm like why would i
be a gold digger
wow when we meet with you and start to
be together i was the person who buy
human clothes and stuff
i was the person he don't buy me now you
have another car
but still but there are some stuff for
myself i want so no need to say
that do you pay your plane tickets
on that but when you come to keep where
are you
typical gold digger trying to save how
would you do that you're so mean
there's balance there's always good you
know to have balance so
that's good to know first of course i
don't see that i am absolutely like i
say
joey that i am paying for 50 50. no i
don't like that i always say that
my money it's my money your money is
your money and my money
funny story whenever we first met we
were like oh
no i was telling her like hey let's go
to uh dominican republic or cuba or
something
and she i was like yeah meet me there
she's like what do you mean
first of all joey you don't invite a
woman anywhere and not
offer to pay for her trip there i just
met her
well you offered you invited her
i mean kind of but we'd only known each
other for like two weeks i was like okay
if this is gonna work like yeah she
could come meet me in cuba
well did you pay for it or did y'all pay
for it i lost
you lost you paid for it right i
wouldn't trust the man who wouldn't pay
for it and just
will tell me to come to the dominican
republic or cuba so
smart move yeah based off the trailer it
seems like
alcohol is about to be a problem in your
relationship
jovi i know this is the question for you
yes i know you're like okay
right do you have any regrets or
anything that you wish
you might have done differently this
season i do have regrets of things that
i could have done differently during the
season
um of course whenever you are arrived to
america i was drinking a lot
i was under a lot of stress i mean we
both were um you know i've been
portrayed oh i'm an alcoholic
i mean in reality i'm not you know i
there are a lot of days i don't drink
there are times i go to work for months
at a time that i don't drink so i feel
like that's only the only kind of thing
that bothers me a little bit is
maybe portrayed as something i'm not but
you know besides that i mean i've been
pretty happy with it
yeah all right well when it comes to the
rest of the season what can you tease
for us
what is in store without giving too much
away
oh yeah i'm just gonna have to watch to
find out if my mom and yara can come to
some kind of agreement of who's gonna
win that battle
yeah are we gonna get that las vegas
wedding yara what do you think
i think yara wants a las vegas wedding
with a big party a lot of people
but i don't know everybody's gonna have
to watch to see
you